bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
session d'information voilà ce que l'on
peut se retenir en ce jeudi 19 mars
l'hiver n'est pas encore fini qu'il faut
penser à l'été en tout cas au job d'été
des forums fleurissent en ce moment
comme à Montini le Bretonneux les
départementales C J3 nous intéressons ce
soir au canton de qui verra entre autres
l'opposition entre deux conseillers
généraux sortants le socialiste Ismaël
van et l'UMP Yve vanval un canton très
élargi et puis dernière ligne droite
donc pour ces élections le président de
la région île-de-fance est venu soutenir
les candidats socialistes à saqu1 en
Yveline l'enjeu est fort trappe mtini ou
encore MPa sont actuellement détenus par
la gauche et puis dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de l'Institut
international de l'image et du son avec
son directeur pédagogie et développement
mais on démarre d'abord ce journal avec
un cocorico local Baptiste Vial élève au
lycée hôelier de guilloncour est devenu
champion de France des desserts dans sa
catégorie junior il a séduit le jury
notamment emmené par le célèbre chef
Thierry Marx avec son dessert intitulé
fraîcheur de pondichir obtient ainsi la
distinction dessert d'or le championnat
de France des desserts existe depuis 41
ans il encourage les futurs talents
élèves professionnel de la restauration
le maître mot nouvelle saveur et
créativité et Baptiste Vial sera
d'ailleurs invité du journal demain
vendredi au chapitre emploi maintenant
le forum sur les job d'été du pôle
jeunesse de Montini le Bretonneux attiré
près de 150 personnes ce mercredi
après-midi au total une cinquantaine
d'offres d'emploi a été affiché sur les
stands les annonces concernaient
principalement les secteurs de
l'hôtellerie de la restauration et de
l'animation on écoute la responsable du
pôle jeunesse de Montini Stéphanie
gar en fait il y a des pistes de eur qui
recrute avec des liens qui renvoi vers
des sites Internet où des offres sont
mises à jour et une sélection d'offre
locale mais aussi sur Paris les parcs
d'attraction le château de Versailles
après c'est aux jeunes à faire la
démarche d'écrire de postuler et en
dehors de cette journée on peut les
accompagner aussi dans la réalisation du
CV de la lettre de
motivation jusqu'à ce qu'il trouve ce
qui correspond à recherche en fait voilà
et puis si vous avez manqué ce
rendez-vous ne vous inquiétez pas sachez
que le pôle jeunesse vous accompagne
gratuitement dans vos recherches
d'emploi estival du lundi au vendredi le
centre est situé sur le parvis des
sources à Montini et puis notez aussi
que la ville de trappe organise un forum
job d'té ce forum aura lieu le mercredi
1er avril de 10h à 18h à la
périsphère politique maintenant derni
dernier canton que nous passons à la
loupe ce soir celui de MPa né de la
fusion du canton de morpa et de celui de
Chevreuse il y a donc deux conseillers
généraux sortants l'UMP Yvan Val et le
socialiste Ismaël
avaD le canton de morpa a été
redistribué il comprend notamment les
villes de MPa coignère manilé amau et
voisin le Bretonneux ainsi qu'une partie
de La Vallette de Chevreuse un canton
élargi et qui compte deux conseillers
généraux sortants ismel avan socialiste
élu de l'ancien canton de MPa en 2008 il
l'emporte au 2è tour avec 40 % dans une
triangulaire qui l'oppose à de candidat
de droite et Ivan Val UMP élu du canton
de Chevreuse conseiller général depuis
2001 et réélu en 2008 dès le premier
tour pour ces élections Ismael avan
s'est associé à Christine Mercier
première maire adjointe à Manil et à et
Yvan Val Alexandra Rosetti et le maire
de voisin le Bretonneux en mars 2014 un
canton entre urbanité et ruralité qui
selon les projections pourrait revenir à
la droite toute élection est très
difficile il existe pas d'élection qui
est qui est très facile donc c'est à
nous de convaincre les habitants de de
ce canton notre priorité c'est de donner
une réponse au territoire aux habitants
en terme de transport en terme de
solidarité l'accompagnement des
personnes âgées et handicapé leur thème
majeur c'est l'accompagnement des
associations d'aide à la
personne le maintien à domicile qui me
paraît très très important les des enfin
penser à à construire des maisons de
retraite accessibles à tous le collège
et les font également partie de leur axe
de campagne les transports il en est
aussi question pour le binôme de l'Union
de la Droite tous les gens qui arrivent
la valchuse passent par voisin et donc
on a quand même des difficultés je
dirais sur certains axes donc je compte
beaucoup moi sur ma présence au
département pour essayer avec vanval de
de faire bouger les choses et d'obtenir
des des aménagements et il faut
également réaliser d'urgence la ligne 18
pour 501 en Eveline parce que ça
conditionne le développement de ce
territoire autre priorité la fibre
optique pour tous et la préservation de
l'environnement veiller comme toujours
sur l'équilibre entre le dynamisme
économique de 50 ans Yveline et par
ailleurs le Parc Naturel Régional de la
houv Chevreuse parce que c'est cet
équilibre qui fonde la qualité de la vie
et l'attractivité du territoire sur ce
canton trois autres binômes sont
également candidats Sophie Brux et
Michel chapaliste d'ivers le binôme
Alain février et briégitte boucher et le
du au Front national représenté par
Isabelle refet et Vincent Texier un
scrutin obseré de près aussi à voisin le
Bretonneux l'élection municipales ayant
été annulées les regards politiques se
tourneront vers le score réalisé par
Alexandra Rosetti dans sa commune le
premier tour de la municipale partielle
est fixé au 12 avril deux rendez-vous
politiques très proches et puis toujours
en politique le président de la Région
Île-de-France Jean-Paul Huchon est venu
apporter son soutien au candidat
socialiste de
50 ans en Yveline ce mercredi l'enjeu
est d'importance pour la gauche sur ce
secteur qui compte actuellement
plusieurs cantons détenus par la
majorité gouvernementale Montini MPa
trappe ou encore plaisir il faut donc
mobiliser les troupes Wifred
richichi des socialistes unis et qui
veulent y croire lors de cette ultime
réunion commune à l'île de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin au iveline monté du FN
abstention deux facteurs que les binôes
candidats espèrent endiguer alors que
vient le moment de faire le bilan de la
campagne du premier tour des
départementales au moment où ça se
termine on se dit toujours mais
qu'est-ce qu'on aurait pu faire encore
qu'est-ce qu'on a pas fait voilà non la
campagne c'est bien passé bien déroulé
bon accueil on sent évidemment que les
électeurs sont débordent pas de
motivation donc il faut vraiment y aller
et aujourd'hui on sent vraiment une une
comment dire un mouvement un peu plus
important qu'il n a quelques semaines
sur la participation et c'est quelque
chose que justement on essay de
combattre le refus de l'abstention qui
s'annonçait et qui peut être important
mais qui s'annonçait plus massif que ça
il y a quelques temps déjà le message
principal c'est de dire aux électeurs B
allez voter et ne vous trompez pas pas
de combat on vote pour le département là
venu apporter son soutien le président
de la Région île-de-fance Jean-Paul
hchon connaît bien les ivelines lui qui
a officier en tant que maire de Conflant
saint-onorine de 1994 à 2001 il sait que
le département a toujours été difficile
pour les socialistes on nous pr une
défaite
sanglante moi je vois il y a beaucoup de
militants sur le terrain je viens de
maison la fite de sartrouille pas des
villes à priori gagnabl immédiatement
par les socialistes il y a quand même un
vrai punch une vraie un vrai tenonus
militant un Jean-Paul huchchon également
candidat à la primaire du PS pour les
régionales de décembre le 28 mai il sera
fixé sur son sort les instances
trancheront et jugeront si elle l'estime
capable de décrocher un 4e mandat al on
va quitter le monde de la politique
l'Institut international de l'Image et
du Son organise une journée portes
ouvertes le samedi donc 21 mars entre
10h et 18h c'est un institut qui est
installé évidemment à hencour et pour en
parler avec nous Emmanuel carré bonsoir
vous en êtes le directeur pédagogie et
développement alors première question
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas les
trois is on y fait quoi il y a quatre
filières alors effectivement c'est
l'Institut international de l'image et
du son et c'est l'image et le son qui
pilote l'ensemble des activités qui sont
traditionnellement orienté autour des
métiers du cinéma et de l'audiovisuel
qui sont les enfin qui est la filière
historique et sur cette filière se sont
développés d'autres enseignements pour
aller vers d'autres métiers art
numérique
spectacle vivant et le journalisme cross
medéia alors le journalisme crossméia on
va s'arrêter là-dessus c'est un peu le
journaliste tout terrain c'est ça on
leur appr on peut dire comme ça on on
leur apprend à tout faire on leur
apprend à monter une émission à la
réaliser à être JRI journaliste reporter
d'images et à savoir jongler entre les
blogs internet puisque tout se numérise
et qu'aujourd'hui l'accès aux images et
aux sons se fait par des des canaux qu'
doivent maîtriser très tôt alors
justement vous dites tout ce numéri ça
veut dire que la filière art numérique
est une la dernière qui a été créée
historiquement oui sachant que l'art
numérique est relié au cinéma dans les
films d'animation 2D 3D et toujours lié
au cinéma par les effets spéciaux et
également tout ce qui est le la motion
capture donc qui va servir pour les jeux
vidéos vous savez c'est des studios dans
lesquels les comédiens ont sur eux des
capteurs capteurs et voilà ça permet de
reconstituer des mouvements à l'image et
c'est ce que Jamel de B utilise dans son
prochain film là qui sort dans une
quinaine de jours dans une Quain de
jours c'est effectivement une demande de
plus imp de plus en plus importante ces
filières numériques ah bah la filière
numérique elle est elle est décisive
puisque on a dans notre hall
d'exposition donc les gens qui viendront
nous voir à cette journée porte ouverte
pour s'en rendre compte on a mis des des
des caméras et des projecteurs des
générations qui sont très très
lointaines puisqu'on a même mis du
matériel de 1980 rendez-vous compte et
on voit en quelques années comment pour
ma génération car na 1980 c'est pas très
très loin mais pour les jeunes ça doêre
très très loin c'est pour ça que le choc
est saisissant parce que on voit le
matériel qui était réputé portable à
l'époque et qui en réalité Ben est très
lourd avec des batteries qui sont
imposantes et on voit comment le
numérique a complètement bouleversé tout
ça alors les tris maintenant installés
auparavant à trappe maintenant à encour
toujours aux deux endroits puisqu'on a
gardé le bâtiment historique dans lequel
on a toute la post-production on a 40
cabines de montage de studios télé et
pour ceux que ça intéresse on fait aussi
des visites à l'occasion des journées
porortes ouvertes combien d'élèves en
tout reçu
en sachant que vous êtes sur la région
parisienne et aussi sur Bordeaux alors
on est on est effectivement sur la
région parisienne et à Bordeaux Bordeaux
ça représente une centaine d'étudiants
et en tout toute promo confondu on fait
des formations de Bac bac+ 3 plus des
techniciens spectacle vivants qui sont
des formations là qui sont accessibles
pour les étudiants qui n'ont pas le
baccalauréat et en tout on a un millier
d'étudiants sur l'ensemble des sites
donc ça veut dire que pour intégrer
votre école il y a pas forcément besoin
du bac pour certaines filières en tout
cas pour le spectacle vivant pour
spectacle vivant technicien spectacle
vivant qui a un titre certifié et qui
dirige les jeunes vers les métiers de la
lumière et du son pour le spectacle là
c'est un titre qu'on appelle niveau 4
dans notre jargon professionnel et là ça
se fait avec sans le baccalauréat je
présume que pour intégrer les 3S il y a
des tests de sélection qui sont faits au
préalable absolument d'ailleurs on a une
journée de concours qui succédera à la
journée porte ouverte la semaine
suivante euh faut candidater en ligne on
a tout qui est sur le site de l'école et
il y a à ce moment-là selon la filière
choisie un exercice écrit qui porte sur
la filière par exemple ceux qui vont
faire art numérique on leur demande de
faire du dessin il y a un QCM un petit
peu sur l'environnement la culture
générale y compris dans les métiers du
cinéma et puis on voit tous les entre
tous les étudiants en entretien tous les
candidats on les reçoit pour voir leurs
projets voir comment alors pour donner
un conseil aux étudiants qui qui nous
écoutent il faut faire faut être comment
à l'entretien alors pour l'entretien de
de motivation en général il faut être
authentique ça sert à rien de répéter le
perroquet de des conseils qu' ont pu
être donnés par d'autres mais souvent
les les étudiants qu'on voit ils ont
souvent une fibre artistique donc faut
expliquer ce qu'ils ont fait dans leur
choix en matière de cinéma souvent ils
ont fait eux-mêmees du montage ils ont
réalisé des choses et certains viennent
avec leur book et ils nous montrent ce
qu'ils font dans le domaine artistique
et puis aussi faut montrer son intérêt
pour la culture plus technique du métier
parce que les métiers du cinéma de
l'audiovisuel sont des métiers qui sont
captivants qui prennent beaucoup
beaucoup de temps et qui demande
vraiment une grande concentration une
une précision pour réaliser une émission
faire le câblage le montage est est
jusqu'au bout dans le sens du détail une
dernière question sur ces journées par
vous avez come c'està dire on pourra ass
des démonstrations he c'est des journées
qui sont vraiment j'allais dire vivante
hein oui le principe c'est que les
portes sont ouvertes ça c'est le début
mais vous avez raison on on demande à
tous les étudiants qui sont organiser
dans des travaux dirigés normaux de
d'organiser par exemple un journal
télévisé donc dans notre sur
d'enregistrement il y a les étudiants
journalistes qui s'entraînent pendant
que dans la régie les étudiants
réalisateurs ben produisent l'émission
pendant que dans la salle de le studio
motion capture il y a des comédiens qui
enregistrent donc c'est vraiment très
vivant ce qu'on veut montrer c'est la la
la réalité des métiers auquels on forme
pour que ça soit concret dans l'esprit
des futurs étudiants merci mon d'être
ven nous parler de l'Institut
international de l'Image et du Son
journée porte ouverte donc ce samedi 21
mars et puis on aura l'occasion
d'accueillir des étudiants des trois is
puisqu'il participeront avec nous à
l'occasion des départementales merci
beaucoup à vous ce journal se termine
merci de l'avoir suivi rendez-vous de
l'information demain vendredi à 18h à
18h30 vous avez rendez-vous avec filco
il sera notamment question d'artisanat
excellente
soirée